like I think we need to kill imposter
syndrome as a word because it's putting
makeup on something we should get to the
root of is a pretty word for insecurity
how do I deal with insecurity the same
way everyone does I either push it way
down and it becomes a cancer or I get
more vulnerable and over communicate
about it or practice making myself
uncomfortable to get over it I didn't
like flying as as a kid I was scared I
fly more than almost anybody now I
struggled with Candor my whole life
without even realizing it once I
realized it I started to address it so
much so I wrote a whole book about it so
you know I think we have to um deal with
it head on even the concept of imposter
syndrome scares me because it makes it a
little bit more thoughtful when imposter
service is insecurity I am insecure that
I don't belong and these people are
better than me how do you get over that
you practice